[Music]
on this Friday night offensive offer
it's disgusting another case of civil
servants suggesting medically assisted
death to struggling military veterans
thwarting threats to democracy ought to
his new plan to beef up Canada's fight
against foreign meddling hashtag
troubling Trend The Surge of hate speech
since Elon musk's Twitter takeover and
who's smarter early birds or night owls
every brain has its own schedule
global national with para Nasser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple good
evening and thank you for joining us
there's a new development tonight and a
story we first reported last summer
about veterans struggling for support
those suffering from life-changing
injuries or post-traumatic stress
disorder don't always get the help they
need and in some cases they've been
offered the option of medically assisted
death veterans affairs minister Lawrence
McCauley has a previously apologized and
said the RCMP is investigating but now a
new case has come to light Marnie blunt
has our top story tonight
for Christine goetzier the fight to get
a wheelchair lift in her home has been
an uphill battle I have to crawl down
the stairs on my on my butt with the
wheelchair in front of me
to be able to access my my house while
pleading her case to a Veteran's Affairs
case manager over the phone in 2019 she
was told something that would leave her
feeling shocked if things are so hard at
this point and uh you just can't keep
going on and you know we can assist you
with the aid to die and she's not the
only one to my knowledge at this time
there is one isolated case that
statement pivoting just two weeks later
two subsequent cases with the same
veteran service agent have been
confirmed bringing the total number of
cases from the employee to four it's
unclear if the VAC worker involved in
those cases is the same one Gautier
spoke with in July 2021 goldsey append a
letter to the Prime Minister stating if
you do not want to allow me to live with
autonomy and dignity put an end to my
suffering and my days but unfortunately
you will need to do it as my convictions
and my faith prevent me from doing so in
a press conference Friday Justin Trudeau
addressed the concerns over Veterans
Affairs I have said repeatedly that this
is absolutely unacceptable and as soon
as we heard about this we took action We
are following up with investigations
Wounded Warriors says it's also making
veterans hesitant to reach out for help
after the first story uh broke on this
particular topic we heard from veterans
immediately saying that they were
fearful to reach out to the department
to reach out to a case manager to to
reach out to the services that there and
benefits that they're entitled to let's
be clear made is not a vac benefit
Wounded Warrior says they'd also like to
see better training and education for
those providing care to Veterans as a
broader systemic change but for these
particular cases they just want to get
to the bottom of what happened and find
find out how many veterans were affected
and how many case managers were offering
a medically assisted death Marty blunt
Global News
Ottawa weeks after global news first
revealed an alleged campaign by China to
influence Canada's 2019 federal election
Ottawa is facing criticism and calls for
Action to curb foreign interference the
Prime Minister has said he was not
briefed on any federal candidates
allegedly receiving funds from China in
a year-end interview earlier today
global national anchor and executive
editor Donna Friesen asked Justin
Trudeau about the impact of that alleged
foreign interference on our elections
well I understand that there wasn't I
think the terminology there wasn't
significant impact was there any impact
though is it possible it didn't sway the
entire election but it may have swung
some writings no uh the the reporting is
at the the analysis shows that it didn't
have a significant impact on any of the
writings but of course
that there is any interference in our
democracies and our Democratic processes
is a very serious thing and that's why
we brought in measures we've continued
to strengthen measures we're going to
continue to make sure that our security
officials and agencies have the capacity
to counter interference
one measure the federal government is
considering to counter that foreign
interference is the creation of a
foreign agent registry Mackenzie gray
has more on the plan and potential
implications Mackenzie
Jeff it's the latest signal from the
Liberals to try and Tackle interference
within Canada the public safety minister
is saying the government will launch
public consultations on implementing a
foreign agent's registry
the goal of a registry shed light on
individuals paid to influence the
Canadian political process on behalf of
other states like China Russia or Iran
country's intelligence officials have
worn for years are meddling in Canadian
Affairs the obligation the former head
of ceases believes this kind of tool
would help law enforcement and security
agencies better deal with that
interference you have an agent of the
Chinese state in one shape form or
another who's registered doing this sort
of thing you have an instant
instantaneous reason for asking them to
exist and possibly Prosecuting them
while no date has been set the
consultations are expected to begin in
the coming weeks and if brought into
force it would put Canada in line with
other key allies Australia and the U.S
have a registry while the UK recently
introduced similar legislation we can
take inspiration from what our partners
have done in Australia United States but
at the end of the day setting something
up locally takes time it was a good day
it's not a New Concept former
conservative MP Kenny Chu proposed a
foreign agent registry back in April
2021 his private members Bill died died
but he wants the government to revive it
as a template for a future registry you
don't have to make it completely
full proof and bulletproof we can
continue to enhance any legislation and
laws as the Liberals are contemplating
the changes new documents obtained by
global news show Canadian officials New
for years the country's existing laws
left holes for foreign governments to
meddle in Canadian politics emails from
senior officials at Global Affairs State
there are several situations not covered
by Canadian law setting examples of an
agent undertaking communication
activities or engaging in big
disbursements of activities on behalf of
foreign governments while the
consultations would be a first step to
implementing a foreign agent's registry
there's no guarantee one will actually
come into place we asked the public
safety Minister's office for an
interview to clarify that point but
Marco Mendocino wasn't available Jeff
Mackenzie gray in Ottawa thanks
and we'll hear more from Donna's
interview with the Prime Minister on
this developing story next week right
here on global national to a major
development now in a case that soured
Canada's relations with China the U.S is
dropping bank fraud charges against
Huawei executive mongwon Joe
it's part of the deal that saw among
released from house arrest in Vancouver
last year the U.S says she abided by the
terms of the agreement including
acknowledging that she concealed the
truth about huawei's business dealings
in Iran Hmong was detained in BC exactly
four years ago at the request of the U.S
Winnipeg was already grappling with a
record number of homicides this year 50
murders with a month still to go and the
city is now reeling yet again from the
news that a killer was preying on
indigenous women some are now demanding
that hate crime charges be laid against
the accused on top of the first degree
murder charges Melissa Ridge reports
it needs to stop and there comes a point
where we have to say that this needs to
stop because it's getting ridiculous
like this is a genocide happening to our
indigenous women we are going missing
left and right and I'm not going to be
next my daughter's not going to be next
and it's sad something needs to change
the daughter of a murdered woman
speaking at a scene too common Gathering
to more and missing and murdered women
at least 11 of Winnipeg's 50 homicides
so far this year are indigenous women
this vigil at the site where DNA of the
latest three victims was found is not
far from where the accused killer lived
their bodies haven't been recovered
painfully many gathered just months ago
for vigils when the women were missing
and now they know the worst happened but
some don't want to believe it no it
hurts they can't find her like how is it
how you supposed to close if you can't
find her
it could be still alive
[Applause]
That's My Hope
this case began last May when partial
remains of Rebecca Contour of the
ochachaka sippy First Nation were found
in a dumpster the rest of her remains
were later found at a landfill while she
seemed to be the first victim
investigators say she was actually the
fourth the first an unidentified
indigenous female in her 20s was killed
around March 15th they believe Morgan
Harris age 39 of long plane first nation
was killed around May 1st Mercedes Myron
age 26 also of long plane first nation
was killed around May 4th and the final
victim 24-year-old Contour was killed
around May 16th two days later Jeremy
skebicki was charged with first-degree
murder in her death his remained in
custody ever since I don't think we've
ever really overcame any grieving
processes of uh of our women that have
been found missing on murdered Justice
officials tell global news that this
matter will not have a preliminary
hearing it's going to proceed direct to
trial at a later date some Advocates say
that they believe that additional
charges should be laid hate crimes
against this accused While others say
that they're left with the feeling that
the national inquiry into missing and
murdered women and girls report is just
collecting dust Jeff
Melissa ridgeen in Winnipeg thanks
Melissa and if you or someone you know
is in need of help or support you can
call
1-844-413-6649 that is a national
toll-free Crisis Line available 24 7 for
anyone who requires emotional assistance
related to missing and murdered
indigenous women
another troubling Revelation from Hockey
Canada the sports governing body says
last season there were more than 900
documented or alleged incidents of on
Ice discrimination
Hockey Canada says its officials called
512 penalties for discrimination-related
offenses which included insults related
to race religion and sexual orientation
another 415 complaints were made
alleging discrimination that was not
caught by the referee 18 percent of
those allegations later resulted in
player suspensions those numbers are
from Hockey Canada's first ever report
on on Ice discrimination part of the
organization's efforts to improve
transparency following a string of
scandals and alleged cover-ups that came
to light this year
well Twitter boss Elon Musk claims to be
cracking down on hate speech on his
newly purchased platform but fresh
evidence suggests the opposite is true
as Jackson prosco reports a flood of
previously banned users are returning to
the site
by opening the floodgates to unfettered
free speech Elon Musk has allowed hate
to spread far and fast on Twitter Elon
Musk when he took over Twitter sent up
the bat signal to every person who has
felt unable to spread racism misogyny uh
homophobia but also disinformation
actors that Twitter's open for business
and why haven't they responded in the
weeks since musk's takeover researchers
found a dramatic 202 percent rise in
tweets containing anti-black slurs a 58
rise in tweets with anti-gayslers and a
60 increase in anti-semitic tweets at
the same time Twitter ended its own
policy against spreading disinformation
about covid it's basically he's going to
create a situation a toxic environment
that's going to shun him and undermine
his his business model so I don't think
he's really realized that though musk
has quickly learned there are limits he
suspended Kanye West and after the
artist tweeted anti-semitic imagery at
the same time Twitter has welcomed back
formerly banned users including
neo-nazis and far-right conspiracy
theorists musk tweeted you know Twitter
is being fair when extremists on far
right and far left are simultaneously
upset the old regime and Twitter their
response was to try to just suffocate
the dissent and and Elon Musk knows
that's not a winning formula half the
site's advertisers like Tech Giant Apple
have now fled and governments are taking
note the EU has warned Twitter could be
banned if it doesn't comply with content
moderation laws a platform that is like
it or not essential to democratic debate
is run by a man who cannot distinguish
the public interest from his interest
what's so particularly concerning is
that the documented increase in hateful
tweets coincides with real world threats
to the same minority groups the U.S
Department of Homeland Security has
warned that domestic and foreign
terrorists continue to use their online
presence to motivate supporters Jackson
prosco Global News Washington
a cautionary tale from an Alberta mother
coming up why her toddlers spent a week
in the ICU
welcome back for weeks Children's
Hospitals have been struggling to cope
with a particularly nasty flu season
kids sick with RSV the flu and covid-19
have led to Long Waits and even canceled
surgeries Heather York's West spoke with
the family of a 23 month old Calgary
girl who became critically ill and spent
more than a week fighting for her life
in the ICU
born on Christmas Day 2020 for her
family Avery Harper was a special
holiday gift but it will be her second
birthday in a few weeks time that will
truly be something to celebrate a trauma
team rushed in
um they were hooking her up to all the
monitors and I was just standing there
Shell Shocked I didn't realize she was
as sick as she was five
the 23 month old is still recovering in
hospital from a terrifying bout with
both RSV and the flu
the family arrived to an emergency
department overwhelmed with sick kids a
triage line out the door but an
experienced nurse could tell Avery was
very sick she immediately pulled her up
in front of the lineup and said I'm
going to get her oxygen checked now and
thankfully she did so we were rushed
back into trauma immediately the little
girl was admitted to ICU and placed on a
ventilator the unit filled with other
children battling mostly RSV and the flu
these photos were taken by Dr Heather
Patterson a Calgary physician who has
been documenting patient and staff
experiences since the beginning of the
covet pandemic to help Inspire Frontline
workers to carry on through difficult
times and across the country Children's
Hospitals now are facing a crisis my
heart breaks for these healthcare
workers like
they're so busy our Health Care system
is on life support I feel right now I I
do feel that it's worse than when covet
first hit because for children it is
with the flu season not expected to Peak
for another several weeks additional
staff is being redeployed from other
parts of the health system to help with
Pediatric Care it will be a tough
holiday for some snuggle up Avery though
Avery will likely be able to spend
Christmas and her birthday back home
Heather your Express Global News Calgary
[Music]
still ahead explosive eruptions the
Wonders and worries flowing from the
world's largest active volcano
[Music]
Hawaiians on the big island are keeping
a close eye on the Mauna Loa eruptions
with both wonder and worry the world's
largest active volcano has been spewing
lava for days on end and while it has
yet to threaten nearby communities
locals and scientists alike are on edge
as Eric Sorensen explains its Mauna
loa's location that makes its volcanic
activity so extraordinary
after almost 40 years the world's
largest active volcano has awakened and
scientists just don't know for how long
nor are they sure how far the lava at
1000 degrees Celsius will travel a major
highway could be in its path the scary
thing is lava flows from monologue can
reach any side of the island and she is
a massive volcano a station that
measures carbon dioxide has been cut off
by the lava flow for the first time in
60 years though so far the lava does not
pose a risk to communities all
indications are that the eruption will
remain in the Northeast drift Zone just
four years ago Kilauea erupted not far
away destroying property and dozens of
homes volcanoes are jarring reminders of
the awesome forces in the middle of the
Pacific that created the islands but can
also destroy life on them
manoloa and Kilauea are among five
volcanoes on the big island of Hawaii
there's a reason that volcanoes are
active here this island is above a
so-called hot spot at this spot deep in
the Earth's mantle molten magma has
pushed to the surface for millions of
years above the mantle the Pacific Plate
the world's largest tectonic plate is
moving Westward each island moving with
it away from The Hot Spot the channel of
magma remains erupting over and over
creating new islands the islands moved
just a few centimeters a year so that
volcanoes on Oahu and other Islands
gradually became less active many the
further west you go are considered
extinct the Hawaiian islands and the
emperor seamount chain before them shows
how over eons the tectonic plate moves
creating a string of islands thousands
of kilometers long and now once again
it's reshaping one small part of the
planet quite fascinating is like a piece
of art and it's also evolving under your
eyes because the taxes very spontaneous
a Wonder to behold at least from a safe
distance it's just pretty amazing that
we get
the molten hot spot is already growing
the next Hawaiian island about 35
kilometers southeast of Hawaii in
geologic time it'll soon break through
the surface though planning a vacation
will have to wait about 50 000 years
Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
wake-up call up next a new Canadian
study Sparks debate between early birds
and night owls
foreign
might find it hard to believe but there
are people who claim to enjoy waking up
early and for those of us who prefer the
snooze button some new Canadian research
is providing a wake-up call it turns out
early risers might be gaining an
intellectual Advantage Mike trolley
reports
take away the bone chilling Lake Ontario
winds sweeping over the boardwalk and
this would have been a beautiful morning
for a jog yet what'd we find early
risers everywhere so what the heck are
you doing up so early well I've been up
early almost all my life so five six
o'clock is my time as it turns out
morning people do this sort of thing all
the time and while it seems quite
frankly nuts they may be on to something
that's because a new study out of the
University of Ottawa took a long look at
the early riser versus Night Owl debate
and came to the conclusion the early
bird not only gets the worm their verbal
skills are sharper as well so yay for
morning people yes absolutely but alas
it's never as simple as that you know
what
if I just start waking up earlier my IQ
is going to go up by 40 points
I mean it would be a nice thing I wish
that was all it cook I would be up first
thing in the morning then if that's all
it was to get smarter
um you'd I'd be up at three so yes when
factoring in age and bedtime the
researchers did find early risers have
an edge
but at the end of the day it comes down
to your natural patterns because our
brains crave regularity and Rhythm but
you know what I think every brain has
its own schedule so it's hard to I know
you're talking about that study but it's
hard to say who functions better
at that moment it wasn't hard to say the
morning person at the edge microwave
Global News Toronto
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Jeff Semple tonight's
your Canada is some pets all decked out
for the holidays we want to see your
four-legged friends in their most
festive outfits so send us your photos
to viewers at globalnational.com and for
the second year in a row we'll showcase
as many as we can on Christmas Eve
thanks for watching hope to see you back
here again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you